so you want to unlock those vaults
containing top to your loot and apex
legends new map world's edge it's quite
simple but there's an element of chance
and it can be dangerous here's a rundown
of what you need to do to unlock vaults
and what you get out of them the first
thing you'll need to do is find a flying
cargo bot of which there are several
roaming around the map it seems that the
ones containing vol keys will have one
panel glowing red which should reflect
on the drone carrying it even as the
container itself cycles through the
different loot tier colors it can be
hard to tell from a distance though not
any old cargo BOTS will have a key and
we're not privy to the chances of
finding these specific ones if you find
this cargo BOTS shoot it down and go
swooped up its loot a volka should be
among the items inside each one I got to
vote the key with the key in your hands
the three vault locations then get
marked on your map all of which are
within tunnels only the key holder will
get this perk when you make it to the
vault it'll take three seconds to get
the door open and you'll be rewarded
with several purple tier and gold tier
items the gear available seems to always
include a purple and gold backpack knock
down shield body shield and helmet be
sure to communicate with your squad
members about who gets what says there
isn't enough for a full team of three to
be fully decked out there can be a few
weapon attachments or healing items as
well we got a purple barrel stabilizer
and shotgun bolt there doesn't appear to
be weapons or ammo within these vaults
however as for some tips when fault
hunting if getting to the vaults is part
of your strategy for a match you'll want
to make it a priority and do it early
other players are probably thinking the
same thing
when looting a vault stay on guard and
scout the immediate area first enemy
squads may camp these locations to
ambush those who have keys to open one
on the flipside that may not be a bad
strategy to do yourself letting another
team hunt for the keys while you get the
jump on them huh that's pretty much all
there is to it
be sure to check out all our other apex
legends coverage including a rundown of
what's new in season 3 our impressions
of the new map world's edge and how to
effectively play as a new legend crypto
[Music]
you